so we have this first story from
everyone's favorite state-funded or what
what Twitter call it State Affiliated
Affiliated media NPR Tennessee house
votes not to expel a second Democratic
member over gun protest so I chose uh
NPR just because I love how they're
gonna smooth out the language here
anti-gun protest is that that's right
yes what was what was the January 6 how
was that then that was just a
um a peaceful uh parade peaceful parade
yeah all right they say after voting
party costume that's right that's right
you know councilman after voting I mean
the police escorts for people in costume
after voting to expel a Tennessee State
Rep for leading a raucous protest a
protest on from the house floor calling
for gun law reform the republican-led
body declined to expel a second member
in the 65 to 30 vote lawmakers failed to
pass a motion that would remove rep
Gloria Johnson who represents about 70
000 tennesseans in Knoxville cheers
erupted blah blah blah three make three
lawmakers acknowledge they didn't follow
the rules of order or decorum and
decorum by speak out without being
formally recognized but they're facing a
disciplinary measure it's only been used
twice since the 1800s gee I wonder why
it is that they're going after uh these
these here protesters could it be um is
it this story I have right here here we
go from 2019 activist Justin Jones
banned from Capital after alleged
assault on speaker Glenn Casada oh
so it was an insurrection but I'm just
gonna I'm gonna skip over the
pleasantries and I'm gonna skip right to
the part where I talk about Civil War
and I'll explain it this way
a few years ago an individual was I
believe arrested I want to make sure I
get that right I believe I believe it
was a ban from the capital
and uh let's see blah blah blah Justin
Jones 23 was charged with two counts of
misdemeanor assault and one count of
disorderly conduct after authorities say
he threw a cup of coffee into an
elevator striking Casada and rep Deborah
Moody a republican from Covington Jones
Vanderbilt student and more than a dozen
other protesters assembled outside the
house chamber on Thursday to protest the
bust of Nathan Bedford Forest a
confederate general
so this is 2019. he actually attacked
attacked members of the legislature and
then a few years later he's in it
so you know I wouldn't call throwing
coffee at someone like a caning or
anything like that but what I think
we're continually seeing with this with
the indictment of Donald Trump and where
everything is going is that the
bifurcation of American culture is now
within the confines of our state and
federal governments to the point where
you actually have a person who
physically attacked Republicans in
office I mean you'd think that would
have been news in the first place it's
like hey remember that guy who attacked
the the legislature he got elected he's
here now well now he's being thrown out
again he's being expelled and their
pledge they're saying you can't keep him
out he will be back I can only imagine
that as we see more of this at the state
level combined with the false charges
against Donald Trump we are heading
towards whatever you want to call it
this country being split in half
well you know it's it's once I would I
would consider it to be one part of the
country has decided just to leave in
terms of refusing to follow the basic
principles I call it the American way we
have this Rising communism within the
Democratic party they reject what we all
have believed in or you know we we
Americans have commonly approved of
which is the rule of law uh you know we
have a republican form of government we
don't vote by mob rule which is what
they try to do in Tennessee
you know another basic respect for civil
liberties and civil rights and and the
Communists don't believe in any of that
they're rejecting it so you know they'll
try to overturn A legislature in
Tennessee they'll try to attack the
Supreme Court here in Washington D.C
they try to jail their their political
opponents in the form of Donald Trump we
see this now with the January 6th grand
jury investigations where they're trying
to jail people for exercising their
first amendment rights on the state
federal constitutional law to dispute an
election so you know that they're
they're kind of throwing out the window
all the sort of norms that we used to
well believe in it's so I mean the
divorce is they're abandoning the family
or even better even worse trying to
destroy it they believe might makes
right that's it well it's it's the
Communists it's you know they can call
themselves whatever they want com you
know they're not going to call
themselves Communists Communists well a
lot of them actually do right
but uh you know this this is the left
this is the the totalitarian impulse of
the left and it's been unhinged and I've
been observing politics for longer than
I care to admit to rarely would I say
something is communist but you know
we're we're facing this communist
revolutionary moment over the last two
years three years and uh I don't know
we're we're an Undiscovered Country when
it comes to that you know my favorite
part of this is we have the story from
the Daily Mail Biden blasts shocking and
undemocratic Tennessee House of
Representatives for vote to expel one of
three Democratic lawmakers so uh if you
as a lawmaker join a violent call it a
riot because they were fighting with
cops and they were actually blocking a
legislator in the bathroom and he had to
be like hugging police officers as they
try and pulled him through an Angry
Crowd screaming and yelling Biden calls
it undemocratic to remove the people who
did that right so what would you call
January 6th what would you call your
justice department been trying to jail
your predecessor
for a speech where he told people to go
peaceably protest about the election
so Biden is approving of an Insurrection
in Tennessee while trying to jail Trump
on pretextual charges for inciting
violence in Washington D.C and the
problem is I see that conservatives keep
trying to argue with the left about why
they're right and it's like bro they
don't care yeah
I mean if you look at the news coverage
of the Tennessee event I mean USA Today
put out this huge like
the coverage of what happened at
Tennessee is completely wrong don't
believe any of it these right-wing
commentators are crazy they're
perpetrating rumors even uh with uh
Justin Jones in the chamber they're
saying oh it's an impromptu protest they
didn't plan it at all it's just that
they had supporters in the balcony and
they strategically knew when to get up
and start protesting on the floor I mean
they are telling you one story not to
win conservatives over but to completely
solidify their base I'm not trying to
I'm not saying they're trying to win
conservatives over of course they are
I'm saying conservatives are trying to
win them over and they're pretending
like it's possible or for some maybe not
even that for some reason there are
conservatives who think that facts care
about feelings that like that Ben
Shapiro standing up and speaking at
University is going to convince people
some but very few right this show the
the the work you do you go to these
people and show them evidence and
they'll go oh wow and then what they'll
do is they'll take the information and
they'll be like they're on to us we got
to adjust our strategy and and try and
find a different way to exploit and gain
power yeah well you know I I would
suggest that the way to think about what
Ben does what we're all doing really is
we're we're trying to educate the
American people and showing leadership
for those of us who are concerned about
these issues the left as you point out
isn't going to be convinced but we got
to speak out and provide leadership and
the truth and let people know there are
people who know what's going on and this
is the way forward but I get that I'm
saying there are people arguing with a
leftist oh yes yeah well there are no
standards I mean the big question I've
been asked about on the news recently
with the Trump thing is what about the
double standards as if they care about
double standards there's one standard
jail them and protect us as far as the
left is going I mean they're being
perfectly consistent which is no rules
we go after you and there's nothing you
can do about it right and then where
it's it's what we're talking about with
Dave Smith the uh the Republicans are
the Washington generals and the
Democrats of the Globetrotters that's
been it's been analogy for several years
now the Democrats pretend like
Republicans are running circles around
them when the Republicans do literally
nothing
and then the Democrats steamroll
everything quite literally indicting
Donald Trump on nothing and two
impeachments two impeachments over
nothing and they're still nervous about
impeaching one of his cabinet officials
who who is partly responsible for uh the
most significant human trafficking
operation in the history of man uh the
the crisis at the southern border uh I
start talking about Biden impeachment
people get very nervous in Washington
D.C let's have an inquiry into what
Biden's done I mean we had news two
weeks not even two weeks ago well I mean
you know that further confirming that
millions of dollars were laundered
through the Biden family Enterprises
from the Chinese Communists has there
been any leadership from the house on
pursuing impeachment for that it doesn't
mean they're not doing some good
investigative work here but to me
there's this urgency and there's this
crisis related to the rule of law our
Republic is tottering it is tottering
and we need leaders that recognizes the
recognize the problem and respond with
the appropriate urgency I I think we're
past that point I mean
I with what's happening in Tennessee
with what's happening with Trump I mean
and as especially with Trump but I think
it's important to point out Tennessee
shows the more Grassroots level of
things the state level the local level
it's happening there the bifurcation
Donald Trump is the first president
former president to be indicted and the
charges are completely bunk right even
even Chris Hayes on MSNBC is like yeah
there's nothing here I mean the statute
of limitations is up what is this
they're doing it anyway because they
don't care they are they're they're
making their moves in slow gradual ways
that are difficult to defend against and
Donald Trump in my opinion should not
have surrendered he should have said
file the paperwork let me know and then
when the media came out and said there's
two things they would gain by this the
media came out and said this indictment
is bunk Trump would have been like well
I don't know what's going I mean MSNBC
said it was there was nothing here so
what am I supposed to do he could use
them and if they do want to pursue it
knowing there's no underlying crime so
this edge of the limitations is up they
would have to contact Ron DeSantis
Administration for extradition and if
DeSantis did extradite Trump he would be
out of the jupy primary like that Trump
would completely just knock him out and
have nothing to worry about but that his
head is probably wouldn't do anything
and knowing that what would end up
happening is Trump would be sitting in
his home he'd say I don't know anything
about this they're free to file whatever
legal paperwork they want and and we'll
read it and then when Bragg fails to get
any support from the cultural left fails
to get an extradition he'd be sitting
there confusing what do I do no one's
going to be like only the weirdos on
Twitter are going to be calling for
escalation so Trump would have just been
like I don't know what happened to that
thing well the weirdos on Twitter seem
to be running
our establishment these days I mean
Bragg but his extremist approach here uh
with the help of Lanny Davis an old
Clinton lawyer who's representing
Michael Cohen that lawyer he brought in
from the Biden Administration was a
longtime Obama hand and these other
leftists and you know the the Soros
approach to uh governance which is to
abuse the justice system to Target your
political enemies and uh you know that's
straight out of the Twitter sphere that
sort of crazy anti-trumpism and it's so
it's so dangerous and and I say there's
like this storm front all across the
Eastern Seaboard from Georgia Fulton
County sane crowd uh same species
allegations trying to abuse Trump for
disputing an election up here in
Washington D.C with with Biden and his
justice department targeting and
harassing Trump and up in New York I
tell you um I I think he's going to get
indicted in multiple jurisdictions and
yeah and I tell you uh Republicans have
got to understand that this is a crisis
that deserves
urgent attention they should be cutting
off funding to the justice department as
appropriate to curtail these abusive
investigations defund New York more or
less defund Fulton County Georgia more
or less
every Power available to them under law
should be used to make sure that Trump
isn't kept as a political prisoner
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time